no more anti-racism protests have been
held across the United Kingdom as part
of the black lives matter movement the
latest wave started in the US after the
killing of George Floyd three weeks ago
but since had spread around the world
one of those to take part was Rose
Hudson Wilkin the Bishop of Dover and
the first black woman bishop in the
Church of England's history just have a
quick listen to some of what she had to
say yesterday and we have been dying
we have been dying in so many ways and
we have been dying in a way that slowly
has also killed the next generation you
can put a stop to it we can put a stop
to it so please let's do that and let's
do it peacefully we just had a little
piece of say sorry to say that we're now
joined by Rose Hudson will conveying on
the program miss Hudson will Kim what
made you decide to speak out at the
protest yesterday you know these were
young people who had organized this
protest march and I felt that the church
I needed to be there with them I
couldn't let them do this on my behalf
or on their own we needed to stand
peacefully together you compared racism
to you coronavirus as saying we've been
dying in a way that slowly has also
killed the next generation do you think
the UK is a racist country do you know I
would be I would be lying if I did not
say that racism exists in this country
as it exists in other countries - this
is not a UK thing this is not an America
thing this is a world thing people who
are black have been experiencing this
kind of injustice for such a long time
and it is about time now as we move into
this century for us all to say that this
is unacceptable this is what is
unacceptable and we must no longer clue
with our silence or pretend it doesn't
matter to me I'm all right jack
we are not all right if one part of
humanity is not okay is there anything
specifically that you would like to see
happen as a result of the protest that
we've seen yes what I want to see is the
kind of social transformation breaking
down structural racism I want every
institution to look at itself I want
them to ask questions like why have we
not got people of all different
backgrounds cultural backgrounds in
leadership within these institutions you
see for too long we have been content in
our organizations in our institutions
and take me for granted but black people
we can do the cleaning we can do the the
work in the kitchen but we cannot sit at
the table for too long we have looked at
black people and said actually they
don't have leadership qualities No
enough is enough we are just as good as
anyone else and as al Sharpton said in
one of his memorial addresses the world
has had its its knees on our necks
preventing us from breathing preventing
the very life that God has given us from
rising and thriving enough is enough
so I want government please no more
reports I want action and the people who
are protesting black and white get if
you look at the groups protesting it's
not this is not a black thing the whole
community is saying enough is enough
I want your organization I wanted the
the media generally I want every
institution including the church to ask
the questions and to make it right
some pretty powerful words there and
some soul-searching no nothing least go
on for many of us you mentioned the
church there now that John sent some you
the former Archbishop of York has set
down the five most senior people in the
church are all white but acceptable it's
not acceptable and you know I you know I
love the Church of which I am a part but
I am NOT going to sit here and tell you
that it's alright it is not okay and so
we to ask the church we must examine
ourselves and it is not good enough for
us to make pronouncements about other
organizations we too must examine
ourselves and can I just very briefly
also say one of the things I've heard
being said is that our generation cannot
make statements about what happened in
the past we cannot speak for or judge
the past by our standards you know I
wonder if I really hearing what you are
saying because in effect what we are
saying is we're saying something about
the moral impoverishment of those who
have gone before us that they would have
thought it was okay to put up statues
and applaud people who had committed
acts of violence against humanity so we
are right today to say that shouldn't
happen I personally don't want those
plaques to be taken away
I want those those statues to be taken
away I would love to see a plaque
written up that tells the true story so
that history can really be told and in
the right way you take it away and it
gets forgotten but just the privileged
few who is able to go into a museum so
that's just my take on that particular
aspect but we have arrived today to make
statements about things that has
happened in the past why because it is
actually impacting on us today do you
know what people say to me I've had
letters of people telling me if I don't
like what's
happening in this country to go home and
they've also said look at you people
look how you're knifing each other let
me tell you something let me tell this
to all of Britain the reason why we're
having those situations on our streets
is because for too long our children
have been told that they are of no worth
that they have no value and they have
begun to believe this for themselves and
that is why they have been destroying
themselves we need to change our society
need to be they need to change and we
need to be the change that we want to
see so I applaud those who are
peacefully standing up to say we want a
different world to live in
just finally you've been a trailblazer
yourself really and you were the first
female black bishop you were day into
the priest in 1994 just a month after it
was possible for women to do so and
you've spoken a little bit about some
racism that you've experienced yourself
saying people rejected you for example
for doing their funerals because you
were black what kind of experiences have
you had and what advice would you give
to others who may be experiencing racism
in their own lives I want to tell you
that I am I'm lucky that I was born and
brought up in Jamaica because growing up
there I my Who I am was cemented I knew
I was somebody so when I came to this
country and people tried to treat me as
if I was a nobody I knew that they were
wrong now you contrast that with someone
who is born and brought up here who do
not have images of themselves in all
walks of life they don't know they don't
know that they are a child of God and
actually they don't need to to
internalize that and so I would say to
those who who are experiencing racism in
a way that impacts on their lives that
you know I long for them to know that
they are special that they are human and
and not to internalize other people's
negativity it belongs to them they
to be healed from its to do not become a
victim it is their problem
unfortunately it impacts on us but we
need to find a way that we can show our
resilience and I come from a people who
are resilient as black people we are
resilient when you think of all that's
happening to us in our history and yet
we can still smile we can still sing we
can still stand there our rhythm our
dance will not be taken away from us we
will still stand and we will seek
justice but not just justice for one
group of people but justice for all
because that is how we're going to live
in harmony with one another black and
white pink and blue young and old
together thank you so much some really
powerful words there as usual Rose
Hudson welcome thank you for being on
the program thank you